jolies choses gilles paquet brenner
c'est un fils d'une grande inventivité
sur le plan formel c'est très très rare
en france de voir des films aussi
sophistiquée sur plan visuel non ouais
mais en même temps il ya une lame de
fond là qui est en train d'arriver bon
enfin il convient à ce qu'on connaît il
ya une cool man mathieu kassovitz
christophe gornès moi je pense que je
fais un peu partie de la deuxième
génération de ce que j'appelle les
réalisateurs cinéphage et cinéphiles
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été élevés au
cinéma américain et aussi au cinéma de
français contre la science de sauter
aussi dans les selles de bistrot donc
une évidence c'est que mon a grandi avec
stallone phare sénégal etc
et puis par ce biais là on est arrivé à
un cinéma un peu plus pointu et et voilà
mais j'ai pas fait d'école j'ai pas fait
tout ça quoi c'est bien un moyen métrage
qui s'appelait le marquis un qui avait
déjà eu pas mal de succès qui avait été
très remarquée et dans ce film la chance
que vous avez c'est que tous les acteurs
sont en participation parce qu'ils
croyaient au projet oui enfin le marquis
simple une histoire de fou c'est un truc
que je me suis levé un matin j'ai dit
dans quinze jours on va faire un film et
en traitant ya patrick bruel son budget
qui se sont trouvés dedans mais wayne le
besco vanessa dému puis des amis à moi
tony romo ni macho bull et mais là je
suis en train de le remonter
et pour pour le ressortir après je pense
directement en vidéo et ce qui est bien
c'est que ça m'a permis de bach on se
rend compte tout ce qu'on commence à
travailler ensemble et pouvoir
poursuivre après sur les jolies choses
alors à une semaine du tournage vous
aviez toujours pas d'actrice pour
interpréter votre ange noir
pourquoi vous avez choisi ophélie
finalement j'ai un peu forcé vous faites
moi j'ai un copain qui m'appelle j'étais
à saint tropez ou chopinot et qu'il n'y
a un rôle super pourtant ils sont appel
au metteur en scène donc j'appelle jean
et il me demande d'en monter à paris je
remonte darda et je supplie de me
prendre pour faire ce rôle parce que
c'était un symbole très trash et que
j'avais envie de faire un saut comme ça
pour changer enfin et j'ai un petit peu
j'ai un peut violer c'est ce que j'aime
bien dire dans les valises et tout le
temps je voudrais une sorte de félines
winter l'envolée quelqu'un qui le dit
pourquoi tu prends pas ophélie winter
tout simplement
et voilà ça fait la blague il ya la
vraie aux prévisions sans film une
chanson du film qui est vachement bien
son matériau
un soir d'axel lenoir très belle très
belle chanson qui va être un truc en
plus non c'est bien alors ophélie c'est
la forme non vous avez déclarez vous a
déclaré le plus difficile dans ce métier
c'est de durer
j'étais tellement jeunes au départ et
puis il a fallu que je réalise ce qui
m'arrivait ensuite tout s'emballe et ça
peut être violent ouais
et c'est vrai que pour vous tout s'est
mis en marche en même temps la musique
la télévision c'était très rapide et
très violents dans cette partie en
flammes
c'est un peu à cause de vous en même
temps je préfère me le dire c'est des
gens ne savent pas mais j'avais fait une
émission juste mais mais dans le même
temps le jury a on vous voit vous aviez
mis dans le jury d'une émission que vous
produisiez et donc quelqu'un de m6 m'a
remarqué ce jour là et m'a proposé
d'autres émissions et après tout est
parti comme ça et c'est vrai que là j'ai
fait un break les deux dernières années
et que c'est pendant ces deux dernières
années que j'ai réalisé ce qu'il m'était
arrivé on va voir l'émission bye et on
parler de titre peut-être qu'on trouvera
un détient classé dans ce classement
dans une dizaine d'années les elfes et
lis tu nous prépares d'un côte d'ivoire
est des simples pour l'instant les 40
citoyens album en préparation
jean tirand doute fin août est-ce que
évidemment comme c'est prévu on aura
quelques titres de prins soutiendra pas
40 12 il y en aura deux voire trois bon
d'accord et pour la montre et j'ai
appris qu'à priori tu devais peut-être
chanter un peu au zénith en première
partie de certains artistes brassée pour
l'instant on va voir à la cigale
c'était la première apparition de bello
winter à la télévision avait été choisi
pour un point dans le jury effectivement
de la coupe du monde de la séduction
salah comme dimanche à la séduction et
puis voilà et c'est laurence au petit
sur m6 qui vous à qui vous a remarqué et
qui a décidé de vous faire faire de la
télé tout a démarré en même temps il y
avait l'album il y avait là il y avait
la télé c'était très rapide a été ça a
été fou et c'était un peu dépassé par
les événements pendant un mois aux défis
qui prône un peu le melon et après je me
suis retrouvé dans la pièce est elle
survit encore très speed vous étiez
surmédiatisé à un moment on peut le dire
moi c'était un peu et si vous vous
souvenez quand on était petits avaient
des bouquins qui s'appelait martine à la
plage du ski j'avais un peu l'impression
d'être martin dans la presse je suis là
pour te quoi ophélie au monoprix au
finish et tout ce qui importe quoi wen
jiabao felli au revoir
oui
alors qu'ils étaient en 1974 est la
fille du chanteur hollandais david
alexandre winter et de kathy winters
mannequin à l'époque et qui est
aujourd'hui votre agent à nos parents se
séparent quand vous avez deux ans et
vous allez vivre donc en france areva en
france et vivra neuilly et votre père
s'en va habiter aux usa et vous dit en
parlant de lui qu'il était lobotomisés
du coeur oui parce qu'en fait j'ai
compris superbe tard quand mon grand
père est à juste avant que mon grand
père sans l'ajfer amber sur son lit
d'hôpital il m'a raconté un truc est
parce qu on est juif donc et dans la
famille quand la les nazis sont arrivés
en hollande mais mes grands parents ont
placé mon père dans une famille
catholique et plus les nazis se
rapprochait plus les familles passé mon
père de famille en famille comme ça donc
il a dû faire cinq ou six familles et du
coup il a re créer ça quand il a été
adulé il fait des gosses partout je
découvre des frères des soeurs en
hollande en belgique c'est n'importe
quoi s'est il a été très généreux de sa
graine mon papa c'est votre mère qui
vous a élevé quatre et donc moins
d'argent quand vous étiez enfant je me
souviens des trucs le pire dont je me
souvienne c'est quand on était à l'école
en louant on avait un appartement et on
le louer pendant qu'on était à l'école
on aller habiter chez des copains
pourquoi mr a un peu d'argent pour nos
fils et à manger dans cette attaque
était souvent les les papes et les pâtes
latin ouais par temps de manger de la
viande c'était la fête
mais bon ma mère a assuré
naciri et malgré tout vous avez quand
même le sens du spectacle chevillée au
corps parce que vous faites votre
premier disque à l'âge de 6 ans aux
ménages étaient pas consciente un maire
qui est je voulais chanter donc l impôt
déguisé et faire ce truc là et j'étais
super en colère après elle mais on a
récidivé à l'âge de 12 ans et là j'ai
dit ça suffit
tous mes copains à l'école ce côté de
moi c'est bon j'ai dit à tous mes potes
vous verrez quand je serai grande ça m'a
mis la rage du quand je serai grande je
crois un indice que ça marchera ya des
coques j'étais assez dur quand vous
étiez petit
mais c'est pas faux pour dix balles vous
arranger les affaires de vaud de vos
camarades d'école j'ai en fait j'étais
grande en sais quoi maintenant que
maternelle en primaire
j'étais assez grande par rapport aux
autres donc je casser la gueule pour 10
francs aux toilettes je faisais des
spectacles jeux rival est content de mes
copines et après ça s'est retourné
contre moi parce qu'au lycée j'étais une
naine pendant trois ans je vais 1 m 40
et là c'était plutôt moins courante à
bastia où j'avais la plus petite de la
classe c'est un petit peu une métaphore
de votre vie parce que finalement tout
le monde va vers vous et puis après vous
vous retrouvez un peu là c'est ce qui
vient de se passer pendant deux trois
ans vous retrouvez un peu la naine de la
classe mais c'est plus c'est bien ça
fait du bien de se prendre une petite
claque dans la tronche comme ça en
devient bien je te montre et vous prenez
votre revanche à l'époque où les grandes
gigues ne sont plus à la mode et c'est
la fin dès la fin des plates et vous
avec m un exact ça m'a sauvé la vie ça
j'ai commencé à être mannequin cette
époque là je partis de chez ma mère je
sais pas j'avais 17 ans jugent est
mannequin est un petit peu rigoler parce
que je n'ai je pas 1 m 68 et j'avais des
saints triple de jeux récents de tour de
poitrine ça n'arrivait d'un coup en plus
jusqu'à 17 ans j'étais comme la table
mais c'est vrai c'est que
ménard long sur la plage voilà je fais
toi tu vois je vais t'attraper
s'additionnent jadis à peu prend
désormais je me sens quand même
alors à neuilly sur le même palier que
vous habitez les frères mc h et yala qui
vous dit vous avez un physique de
chanteuse
ouais c'est des phrases de films sa
toiture de serres du championnat n'ont
pas encore là
et oui donc commune et c'était mon
voisin et que je voyais sortir son chien
depuis des années je pensais que c'était
quelqu'un de bien donc j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui et ses frères s'est
avéré que ça c'est pas super bien passé
donc j'ai fait un divorce de producteurs
qui a duré un an et qui m'a empêché de
chanter pendant un an
non non ce n'est pas chanter j'ai
profité pour faire de la télé sur m6
mais en expliquant quand même à qui
voulait l'entendre que ce n'était pas le
but de votre vie et c'était juste un
passage
c'est l'époque aussi de votre relation
avec prins alors on n'a jamais su ce qui
s'est passé parce qu'un jour je vous ai
posé la question dans un journal et vous
m'avez dit le premier qui parle doit
payer je sais plus combien 1000 $ à
l'autre chez par ouï oui j'avais une
petite amourette avec 13 il ya
prescription maintenant toi si on peut
en parler est fou ouais c'est fini ouais
les nombreux voyages à minneapolis entre
mais c'était génial ici ne désire pas la
téloche toi j'étais encore à l'école
j'avais 17 ans ce encore l'école
ouais ça commençait vachement tôt il le
vendredi soir quand j'ai quitté l'école
je prenais l'avion je faisais paris
boston boston minneapolis et janvier le
dimanche donc il est inutile de dire que
les devoirs et les courges n'importe
quoi et que ça va durer longtemps ça se
voit que vous avez juré aventure et
galabru t'aurais pas redoublés non plus
ouais
april a eu sa
m
moi je
je
alors ça c'était en fait le quatrième
essai discographique et 8,3 échec avant
et c'est génial parce que vous dites
finalement au point où j'en suis
maintenant je me suis tellement planter
autant faire ce qui me plaît
glorifier dieu voilà c'est l'idée que
vous aviez et dieu vous a aidé
apparemment aide toi le ciel t'aidera un
truc comme ça je sais pas mais j'avais
vraiment envie de parler de ça je me
suis toute façon personne ça n'intéresse
personne dieu 28 mai copains quand je
leur ai fait lire ma chance on y attend
et n'importe quoi et finalement ben
voila c'était la belle surprise et alors
là c'est un peu le début du délire parce
que vous déclarez à l'issue de ce succès
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être
prédestiné bon jusque là d'avoir une
boule de feu au dessus de la tête
oui elle à l'époque j'avais un peu de
mal à m'exprimer donc non mais j'ai pas
une boule de feu mais j'avais fini je
peux pas en parler là mais qu'est ce qui
s'était passé j'ai fait une séance
d'hypnose une fois pour arrêter de fumer
et c'est à dire est que ça va pas
marcher
ça n'a pas marché mais c'est tant mieux
et j'ai lu une image comme ça de
joaillier les gens comme des boules de
feu c'était en fait c'étaient les âmes
qui étaient comme des petites boules de
feu qui disent qu'ils parlaient en
faisant de la télépathie
vous avez l'impression que vous aviez
aucune maîtrise de votre carrière si on
faisait un petit peu tout ce qu'on vous
demandez où plein quand j'étais choix
assez aléatoire n'est pas connu et que
tu en rêves depuis que depuis que tu es
petit tu fais n'importe quoi et c'est à
dire une fois que j'aurais pu faire une
ouverture de prisunic avec un string
panthère j'aurais fait n'importe quoi
pour être connu ce que j'en rêvais et
comme ça un peu marcher je me suis dit
ma mère me disait tout le temps tu
profites profite parce que ça peut très
bien s'arrêter demain donc je me disais
[ __ ] [ __ ] vite oui alors oui toi oui
et je me retrouve à dire oui à tout le
monde à faire dès ce qui n'avait ni
queue ni tête
ce que je ne sais plus aujourd'hui et
cette histoire avec mc solaar s'est
terminé comme en moi comme une rupture
de gens normaux c'est une rupture n'a
pas à faire ouais normal quoi contribuer
avec en même temps cinq ans et demi